peut-être lé liban était très très loin
de cela en 1960 est peut-être
aujourd'hui elle est très proche et donc
peut-être une politique d'ingérence et
les changements de régime en 1981 est
vouée à l'échec et un 2029
c'est exactement le petit effort qu'il
faut pour les aider à passer à autre
chose
donc je pense pas que changer de régime
c'est exclu ce n'est pas jamais marché
mais notre expérience c'est que prendre
le monde dans le monde arable ça arrive
trop tôt malheureusement peut-être en
afrique aussi c'est trop tôt et donc il
faut il faut arrêter de l'essayer mais
je pense que au liban peut-être la
société murs pour passer à autre chose
on voit que des l'intérieur il ya un
véritable volonté même si c'est vrai
qu'on voit essentiellement ce qui se
passe à bayrou tu es moins ce qui se
passe à tripoli aux rats bint jbeil au
moral est haut dans le bac à mais
j'imagine que c'est assez représentative
donc il ya quand même des forces ils
sont des forces nationales et non plus
les forces de la de l'état d'avant qui
est en sorte de confédération des
confessions
[Musique]